well thank you for talking to me i am
always happy to talk
about a show with a dog because who
doesn't want to do that
definitely agree although when you did
this
i mean was there like a conversation in
the beginning when you were like does
this involve
hazard pay because of all the dog drool
like was there
any sort of initial conversation about
just what you were getting yourself into
oh my gosh well these these french
mastiffs i think might have the most
talented salivary glands of any dog
breed
i'm not sure the drool load comes
close with any other dog but
yeah i mean there were just moments
where i'd have like a 150 pound
you know dog on my chest cutting off
circulation in my diaphragm while all
also like bathing me in their saliva and
thinking like if i wasn't a dog person
before i
surely am one now and oh and i don't
think i've mentioned this at all yet
and then you know when we would need
them to lick my face
they'd have to first put on like a layer
of baby food of like
chicken baby food and then the dog would
lick my face so it was like it was a
double disgusting
it's like if the dog food didn't or the
dog licking didn't make you want to gag
the baby food did so you just had to
embrace the gross
with this show totally and eventually
you just give over to it and you're like
oh just have me
you know i'm just a gigantic toy for you
after doing this have you learned
any tricks for making a dog drool less
or is that just not possible
yes if you want them to drool less don't
feed them like
too many treats um because and obviously
our dogs like
they react for tweets or i'm sorry they
react for treats
much like myself and uh and
so you know you'd constantly see like
after each take if they were getting a
little bit of like meat or cheese or
something
that it just was like the waterfall
would begin
so sometimes we'd be like all right
let's do a treat every other take
just so that we don't need to bring in
like a whole um
mop team after this
when the opportunity to lead this show
came your way
what was your reaction to that had you
been familiar with the movie
were you immediately curious about it
you know it's a great question i i it's
funny i think uh
turner hooch for me like many people is
in that
i there are some people i know who
haven't seen the movie but there's no
one i know who hasn't heard of it
it just has an incredible name
recognition
and i had seen bits and pieces but i
didn't watch the whole thing until i
knew i was auditioning for the movie
and so i felt really excited at this
idea that it was a continuation
it was pain homage to the original but
it wasn't a remake
which i think is just dangerous
territory because you don't want to mess
with people's memories they're very
sensitive
so i i just love the idea of jumping
back into family fair which i've always
sort of
um you know paid my dues it's where i
come from
in this new elevated way that was a
challenge for me
and not kind of just like the typical
sort of broad comedy stuff that i'd
always done
was it ever completely surreal when you
were recreating the poster
that tom hanks had done for the movie
oh my gosh i mean it's just he's always
you know someone like tom hanks is
always in your mind
because he's just one of our greatest
you know the
one of the greatest actors of a
generation and
he did this at such an interesting time
in his career because he like just
finished big
but he hadn't done horse comp yet so you
know he's like right at the precipice of
like the apex of his powers and ability
and so i think we were just all sort of
banding together to do something that
hopefully would make him proud
and i don't know if disney's been
sending him early episodes but
if you want just you know mr hanks if
you want to see someone i have a couple
i can email to you i i'd love to share
them with you
and yes we can have coffee anytime
anytime
i'll come to you it's such a fun show i
can't imagine he wouldn't enjoy it in
some way
i hope so i hope he likes it and i hope
he feels
uh we just tried to honor him in the
memory of the original
you've led and played the title
character of a show before
how different does it feel doing that at
this point in your life
well i think what's exciting is helping
to sort of launch what's
a bit of a new streaming service in
disney plus
and being part of something that is
really building
and it's building at a wild pace because
you know my wife and i just fell in love
with
we just watched the first episode of the
new mighty duck series and
my friend uh john sneemos is starring in
big shot like
i think the fair the the the shows that
are already on disney plus are so good
so it's exciting to be
um starting something new and also
i just feel like i you know
i love doing family fair but i think for
the most part we've always seen
things that either really appeal to kids
and parents would grudgingly watch
watch with their kids and vice versa and
it's rare to have something where
each demographic can completely find
something to love about the show
be it the action-adventure stuff with
the us marshalls the rom-com
the cute dog stuff i mean i i truly
believe there's something for everyone
and
i mean mcgee directed our pilot so it
looks really good too which i think is
important yeah that's
one of the things we found really
impressive about these shows is i've
watched
you know the whole season for the mighty
deck series i've watched all of
big shot i've watched the episodes we've
been given for this
and it's amazing how with each one it it
recreates that feeling
that you know a lot of the movies or or
shows or things of
the time period of turner and hitch had
that that sense of
you know just they're just sweet and fun
and it puts a smile on your face
and feels like a warm hug when you're
watching it and it's kind of tricky to
do without
feeling too sappy or sentimental
that's a great point no i think that's a
really good assessment you're right
like it's just high-end family material
that i'm not sure
has been done in a really long time and
i think you know
it i just think it was really smart of
disney plus to realize that there's so
many streamers out there like
what can we do great you know what can
we do that's specific to us
that's maybe an untapped market and i
think they're really succeeding in this
way
when you do something like this where
obviously the relationship with the dog
is so important at what point did you
meet and start working with the dogs
what was it like to sort of
develop a relationship with five of them
so even in the audition
actually and it was when i knew i was
working with really smart
collaborators they told me you're going
to be auditioning with a dog
it wasn't actually a french mass ship it
was like a great dane i think it was
like the only giant
um movie dog that was available that day
and you're going to be working with a
dog and be ready to improvise because
obviously we know the dogs will do what
they want and it's it's
incumbent on us to adjust which
immediately made me feel like wow
you know people like the creator matnix
they just they get it
because i've certainly worked with
animals before and i've worked with
certain people that are
that have been like wait the dog's not
gonna bark
right at the moment we need it to and
and be you know stay on its mark
perfectly like
well no it's an animal and it'll get
close to that and then we'll adjust so
i think that was like a big part of it
was knowing that and then
and then basically i flew to vancouver
quarantined for two weeks
and then we had two weeks of prep before
starting a film
and the dog trainers were like hi you're
going to be our new best friend now
and it was just like you know
a lot of times was just hanging out with
the dogs because they had to trust you
and feel comfortable
so it was like let them know that i am
literally
a pez dispenser when it comes to treats
that every time they're around me
they're just going to be rewarded and
it's going to be a love best
and then we would start practicing
certain tricks whether it was like
getting um one of the dogs to like stick
his head through my arm
or you know jump up on me certain
certain specialty things
you do you have action and physical work
on the sense side of things but you also
have a lot of physical comedy in this
what's it like to find each of those
things are they very different from each
other
do you find them both fun to do
oh i love it i i i mean i just love the
physical comedy um that i grew up with
especially in the 90s when you watch
like the masters of it from people like
chris farley and
jim carrey and um just you know robin
williams like the geniuses
of that type of work and then but then i
remember my acting teacher always told
me and i remember when we worked in the
audition for this
she was like play the reality of it and
the ridiculousness
of the stakes of you being pulled by
this dog
will make people laugh but if you're
kind of like
sticking it up and making it broad she's
like it kind of breaks a fourth wall
like
if you're really committed to how much
you're trying to control
this 150 pound dog who has no interest
in control
then the comedy will be more than that
and i think that's true so i love it
um and then with the action adventure
stuff you know
playing the us marshall i did ride
alongs with real us marshals i spent a
lot of time with them
i did a weapons training with taran
tactical who did the john wick movie so
i
i was able to learn that stuff so i
didn't feel like a phony
when it came to feeling like i could
save someone but it must be so much fun
to get to add the humor to it too so
that you're not
just doing this dark cop drama you
actually get to have that side of it but
then also
the comedy of it no i think that's a
great point my friend
who i made a movie with he's these great
actor named james ranson
once said i'm the kind of actor that can
punch a guy in the face but i'm gonna
have to go like this after
oh like and that's me
yeah like i can do the cool action guy
thing to it to a point but
usually i need that pressure valve
release of like
the funny moment that because all of a
sudden if i'm adding that level to it i
feel like i belong in that world whereas
you're right like in a typical cop
procedural
procedural playing the stoic gruff
you know officer i'm not sure that would
be my uh
my strength have you already had
conversations and thought about
what you would want to do in another
season do you or do you start to like
come up with your own wish list of what
season two could have for you
oh my gosh um you know i think like
just knowing that there's so much to the
show and there's so many
relationships like my sister played by
lindsay fonseca
and um the character of erica
they're both sort of in the animal world
and knowing that they could team up and
start working together
and that you know my sister played by
lindsay her name's laura turner
so in a world you know there could be
certain episodes where laura turner
and hooch are solving things and maybe
i'm doing more of the recon work behind
the scenes and by that i mean
not getting licked by the dog every
scene
um but it just seems like with our cast
and the possibilities here
it it i i can't see these episodes
getting stale anytime soon i think
there's
a wealth of possibility it must be so
fun too to have reginald johnson
come on to set sort of as that bridge
from the original movie but also
just like who doesn't love some
character that he's played before
you're so right having reginald on set i
mean
obviously he played tom hanks's uh
partner in the original
but he also is from die hard and family
matters
and like and i'm such a stan like i'm
such a reginald bell johnson stan
then i'm sure at times he was like why
is the lead of this show bothering you
so much
but i just wanted to know like when
jaleel white took off his glasses and
became
step on like was that cool
um so he's just he's
a beauty and like a real actor's actor
like went to tish
went to nyu like just a great energy to
be around
yeah he's just played such lovable
characters that it's hard not to love
him
and a guy like that who's like in his
late 60s early 70s like
could easily just be like hanging out
enjoying life
and yet he just wants to keep working
which i
i hope i'm the same way one day well
thank you for talking about the show
i'm excited to see more of it i've had
so much fun with the episodes
i'm so glad to hear it thank you